>>> IT'S SO SWEET.
YOU GOT THESE ONESIES FOR ALL
THE KIDS.
>> YOU KNOW HE'S GOING TO BE A
HEARTBREAKER JUST LIKE HIS DAD.
>> OH, LOOK.
THEY'RE LIKE A TINY LITTLE BABY
COUPLE.
>> NOT TO ASSUME.
MAYBE THAT'S WEIRD FOR YOU GUYS.
I'M SORRY.
>> NO, WE THINK IT'S CUTE.
>> YOU LOVE SEEING YOUR LITTLE
ONE AS A FUTURE HEARTBREAKER.
BUT WHAT IF YOU DON'T WANT TO
ASSUME YOUR BABY'S GOING TO BE
STRAIGHT?
NOW YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
WITH THE NEW FORMED THIS WAY
LINE FROM OSHKOSH B'GOSH.
YOUR LITTLE TYKE WILL LOOK
ADORABLE WITHOUT BEING SO
EXCLUSIVE.
WITH SAYINGS LIKE "FUTURE
TWINK."
"LIL' LES."
"MESSY DJ."
AND "IN THE CLOSET" BECAUSE I
CAN'T WALK.
>> I PRAY TO GOD MY SON IS GAY.
>> I WOULD LOVE THAT.
>> BORN THIS WAY HAS DESIGNS
YOUR BABY WILL LOVE.
LIKE WORDPLAY.
>> ROCK-A-BI BABY.
>> MY MOMMY HAD A DADDY.
>> POLITICAL STATEMENTS.
>> I LOVE MILK.
HARVEY MILK.
R.I.P.
>> SILENCE EQUALS VIOLENCE.
BUT CRYING EQUALS HUNGRY.
>> ALEXANDER HAMILTON WAS A
TURF.
>> AND BUTCH.
>> OH, WHAT IS THIS?
A TINY BELT LOOP FOR A RING OF
KEYS?
THIS SLAYS.
>> SOME PARENTS FORCE THEIR KIDS
TO WEAR LITTLE SPORTS JERSEYS.
MY SON CAN BE WHOEVER HE WANTS.
>> IMAGINE BOXING A CHILD INTO
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T FEEL
RIGHT.
>> I WOULD HATE THAT.
>> IT'S SO ARCHAIC TO PIERCE
YOUR BABY'S EARS FOR THEIR
BAPTISM.
OUR KIDS WILL NEVER HAVE TO
CONFORM TO SOMETHING THEY DON'T
WANT.
THANKS, BORN THIS WAY.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE DATING.
>> OH, PLEASE.
THEY'RE NOT EXCLUSIVE.
YOU KNOW HOW GAY GUYS ARE.
>> BORN THIS WAY.
FROM OSHKOSH B' GOSH.
OH, RELAX.
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY CAN READ.